Well,
I think everything,
whether it's filmmaking,
photography,
music,
uh,
especially in electronic music 20 years
ago,
making electronic music was really
difficult.
You know,
you had to have obscure pieces of
equipment and you had to figure out how
to make them all talk to each other.
And so finding the equipment was
difficult.
Getting it to work was difficult.
And now everything exists on a laptop,
you know,
just like individual pieces of software
that do everything for you.
So on one hand,
I love that because it's very
egalitarian and the software worked
flawlessly and it sounds great and
anyone can use it.
But at the same time,
I mean,
we run the risk of everybody being an
artist,
which on one hand is great,
but it just means that if everyone's an
artist who's ever going to stop and
listen to what other people are doing,
you know,
if everybody's making music,
then everyone's just clamoring to get
their music listened to,
which might not be such a bad thing.
But
my website,
[inaudible] dot com started in I think
1999 99 or 2000 and it started just as a
way of making people aware of upcoming
shows.
And it sort of evolved into a lot more
than that,
especially as bandwidth increased.
For me.
The website is just a fun way of
communicating directly with people.
You know,
in the old days the only way you could
communicate with an audience member was
through like,
you know,
different media outlets or through the
gatekeepers at the record company.
And now I can communicate very directly.
And I also just recently started a
website called [inaudible] dot com that
takes music that I've made and gives it
away for free to independent filmmakers
and film students.
Uh,
and that goes through moby.com as well.
I started moby gradis.com cause a lot of
my friends who are independent
filmmakers are film students complained
that the hardest part about making a
film is actually trying to license
music.
You know,
cause they don't have budgets.
And so the record companies don't return
their calls.
The publishing companies don't return
So I started [inaudible] as a way to
just give free music to my friends who
are independent film makers.
And the response from that community,
the independent film community has been
great.
And we've had about 8,000 uses so far.
You know,
it's been using,
well not 8,000 different films,
but 8,000 different uses.
So,
and we've only,
thus far,
for the most part,
publicized it to people in the
independent film.
Okay.